[Music]
rat killing combined with basic measures
of rat proofing and sanitation
constitutes a major step in permanent
rat control
but rat killing by itself does not
result in permanent rat control
so long as food sources and harborage
remain undisturbed
killing rats merely lessens competition
for those that survive
with less competition
rapid reproduction rebuilds the
population
soon the infestation is as great as ever
when a building has been rat proof to
keep rats out
it is possible to eliminate all rats
within the premises by the techniques of
rat killing
it is the rat eradicator's job to get
rid of every last rat remaining in the
premises
one surviving pregnant female might
cause a reinfestation that would
completely nullify the effort and
expense of rat proofing
the tools of rat killing are various
rodenticides and mechanical devices
the selection and use of these tools
depends upon the area to be made rat
free
for instance in this rat proofed
restaurant kitchen
no chances should be taken with the
poison that rats might spread to human
food
in this case red squill is selected as
the rodenticide
red squeal is relatively safe around
humans and most domestic animals
since it is in itself an emetic and is
normally regurgitated before lasting
harm is done
but the rat cannot regurgitate and
retains the poison
for this reason red squill is the most
commonly used rodenticide
but the problem is to get the rat to eat
the red squirrel
red squill is bitter
therefore it must be mixed with food
that is highly acceptable to rats
a poisoned bait is prepared of fresh
lean ground beef and chicken mash
mixed with red squeal
salad oil is added as a binder
the mixture is prepared in small amounts
called torpedoes for distribution to the
rats
an alternate cereal poison bait is
prepared of steamrolled oats ground
bacon and red squeal
experience has shown that better results
are obtained if a choice of food baits
is offered to the rats
again salad oil is used as a binder
the preparation must be made attractive
to the prospective customer
the cereal and meat baits are wrapped in
contrasting paper so that the
eradication man can distinguish one from
the other and thus can learn which bait
the rats
the poisoned baits must be placed where
the rats can easily find them
it would be too much to expect the rats
to search for them
bait is placed along runways and near
customary sources of food
to kill as many rats as possible before
they develop an aversion to the poison
a generous supply of bait is used
rats seek food where they have
previously found it they are usually
suspicious of any change
however in the absence of their regular
food hunger will induce them to accept
any food they can find
rats in the open are normally nibblers
and samplers
they usually eat a full meal only in the
safety of their harborage
for this reason the torpedoes are made
in a convenient size for the rats to
carry away for later eating
each torpedo contains enough rodenticide
so that if later it is shared by two or
three other rats each rat will receive a
lethal dose
red squill takes from 24 to 72 hours to
kill
when a rat is eaten red squirrel it
usually becomes lethargic in one to two
hours
four to fourteen hours later
characteristic tremors begin
followed by progressive paralysis
if it can the rat will return to its
harborage
thus death usually occurs in the nest
since up to 90 percent of all rats
poisoned with red squill tend to die in
their nests or in secluded places
it is difficult to determine how many
rats have been killed
a checkup in the restaurant kitchen two
days after setting out the poison
reveals lessened rat activity
a definite odor of dead rat coming from
behind the stove guides the eradication
man to one of the rat casualties
[Music]
another wrath dead before it could get
to its nest
judging from the smell there must be
still another rat in the hole
unfortunately it is out of reach in the
double wall
ripping out the wall would be expensive
the best thing to do is to cover the
odor with a masking agent such as
isobornel acetate
have all the rats been killed
well that's hardly likely
the best way of finding out whether any
rats are still living
is to put down some patches of talc or
paropalite or 10 ddt dust to make rat
tracks easily visible
a patch approximately 12 by 18 inches
and about 1 8 inch thick is spread and
smoothed with a straight edge
smoothing will make it easier to see the
tracks clearly
because rat signs age slowly
it is impossible to tell from them the
progress of day-to-day eradication
the tracking patch is the best way of
determining the extent of rat activity
during a given night
the tracking patches are laid along the
rat's principal routes between food
water and harborage
in view of the rats limited home range
patches must be so placed that every rat
present will traverse some patch during
the night
too few patches or patches poorly placed
can give a false impression that all
rats have been killed
early the next morning the patches are
examined with a flashlight before the
kitchen is cleaned for use
the first patch is smooth
this patch clearly shows tracks of
several wraps
the flashlight is held at an angle of
about 30 degrees to the floor so as to
throw into relief the impressions in the
dust
obviously the job is not completed yet
and by now the surviving rats have
probably developed an aversion to red
squirrel
therefore the rat control man decides to
use n2 to complete the kill
and two is unique in that it can be used
as a tracking poison
the control man removes the old patches
in order to avoid diluting the antu
mixture
and you is specific for norway rats
while roof rats have a high tolerance
for it
next the control man lays down new
patches consisting of a mixture of
twenty percent and two dust and eighty
percent corropolite
even though expensive and two is
economical when used under ideal
conditions
in this case the rats have become
accustomed to tracking patches in their
runways it is virtually certain that the
rats will come into contact with the
rodenticide
in their search for food the rats run
through the anterior dust
the dust irritates the rat's paws
causing them later to lick their paws
thus ingesting the anti-dust
andrew causes an overproduction of
liquids in the rat's lungs
within 48 hours the rat dies as though
by drowning
when no rat tracks appear on the
tracking patches for five nights
the eradication man knows the restaurant
kitchen has been freed of rats
rats may re-enter a rat free and rat
proof building through an open door or
with merchandise deliveries
to maintain the kitchen in a wrap-free
condition
inspection is necessary
inspection must be at regularly
scheduled intervals so as to find any
reinfestation as soon as possible
sometimes the rodenticide selected does
not work too well
in this fish market torpedoes containing
red squirrel bait have been tried
but for some reason have proved
ineffective the surviving rats will no
longer take the red square bait having
developed an aversion to it
since the rats have been feeding mainly
on fish and fish scraps the eradicator
decides to use arsenic trioxide in a
fish bait
the arsenic trioxide is added to
animatic in this case tartar emetic and
weighed carefully
the tart aromatic is intended to protect
animals other than rats by causing them
to vomit the poison
the poison and the medic is added to the
fish
finally the bait is prepared in
torpedoes
as an alternate base ground breadcrumbs
and ground bacon are mixed with the
finely powdered emetic and the arsenic
trioxide
this second vape is made into torpedoes
again contrasting paper is used to
distinguish them from the other bait
in the fish market these poisoned baits
are readily taken by the rats
arsenic trioxide is a poison which is
absorbed into the rat's intestinal tract
causing gastroenteritis destruction of
kidneys exhaustion and generalized
paralysis
death usually occurs in less than 24
hours
although in a few cases where minimal
lethal doses are eaten it may take up to
six days
to check on the possibility of any rat
surviving
tracking patches are put down
in this case the patch is laid in a 15
inch radius around the rat hole
making it impossible for any rat using
the hole to avoid leaving its tracks in
the patch
thus well-placed tracking patches offer
a check on the effectiveness of any
specific treatment
in addition to indicating the presence
or absence of rats tracks found in such
patches often indicate the size of
surviving rats and the number of rats
using the runway
such tracks are also a clue to the
direction and purpose of rat travel
only when an adequate number of properly
placed tracking patches are free from
rat foot prints for five nights in
succession can the premises be
considered rat free
a quick acting highly toxic rodenticide
such as 1080 water
can be used only when the premises can
be effectively closed off to humans and
animal pets
when the area contains food it is
necessary to cut off all sources of
water and rely on the rats thirst to
force them to take a waterborne poison
1080 water is placed in waterproof
non-spillable cups
1080 is a very dangerous poison
only trained and experienced eradication
men should be permitted to use it
the utmost precautions must be taken
whenever 1080 is used
rats must have water
water is tasteless odorless and quite
acceptable to them
one swallow is a lethal dose
1080 kills within one half to two hours
for some unknown reason a high
percentage of rats killed with 1080 die
in accessible places and are easily
recovered
convulsions precede death by heart
failure
the next day
the first order of business is to count
pick up and dispose of cups and
carcasses
dead rats and every used 1080 cup should
be incinerated
only licensed and qualified eradication
men should be permitted to use 1080
and then only under carefully supervised
conditions
with 1080 as with other rodenticides
tracking patches are laid to determine
whether all the rats have been killed
this basement storage room has been rat
proof
but colonies of rats still remain and
have to be exterminated
the rat control man decides to try
another rat poison
warfarin
warfarin was originally known as
compound 42
strictly speaking it is an anticoagulant
causing a slow bleeding to death
it is tasteless and odorless
one effective bait to use with warfarin
is cornmeal mixed with a discoloring
agent such as activated charcoal to warn
against human use
warfarin mixed with yellow cornmeal and
charcoal
is placed in a bait box near a rat
entrance
the purpose of the bait box in this case
is not to prevent human access
but to avoid the poison being kicked and
spilled accidentally
the use of such a bait box is optional
the box contains enough bait to last
until the next service date
a tracking patch is spread around the
bait box to indicate the presence or
absence of rats
another bait box is located near a place
where the rats have fed in the past
tracking patches are placed around this
box also
during the night the rats are attracted
by the bait and approach the box
as no other food is uncovered and easily
available
the rats investigate and find the food
to their liking
unlike other poisons warfarin does not
create an aversion in rats that eat it
they come back again and again
rats often show a preference for
warfarin in cornmeal over other foods
even though the other is unpoisoned
the next day examination of the tracking
patch shows the rat's reactions to the
bait
they have eaten so much that it's
necessary to replenish the supply
the effect of warfarin is cumulative
repeated doses over a period of several
days will gradually weaken the wrath by
loss of blood
the rat usually dies between the fifth
and eight days
the slow cumulative effect of the poison
delays the rat's death for several days
thus warfarin is dangerous to domestic
animals only with repeated ingestion
despite its safety features warfarin
must be used with caution
placed in a bait box or in inaccessible
locations where humans and household
pets cannot get at it
with warfarin just as with all other
rodenticides tracking patches are needed
to indicate the presence or absence of
surviving rats
for ten days after the last rat was
found dead
there have been no tracks around the box
yet another patch near the rat entry
hole
shows the tracks of more than one
surviving raft
since warfarin won't complete the job
the bait boxes are removed
but the remaining rats must be killed
the eradicator decides to use steel
traps
he selects one carefully sets it at hair
trigger
and places it at an opening to rat
harbour it
because a steel trap does not kill the
rat outright
it must be securely fastened so the rat
cannot drag it to his harborage
to force the rats to cross the trap
the eradicator puts a box on each side
of the trap
the boxes are pushed back against the
platform to prevent the rat from turning
aside to bypass the trap
after setting out sufficient traps he
puts out additional tracking patches and
smooths the old ones
the next morning inspection shows that
one rat has been caught in a trap and is
still alive
another trap has evidently been sprung
and dragged around
but there is no rat in it
the tracking patch near the rat entry
reveals a rat's footprints
since the eradicator now has made the
rat shy of steel traps
he prepares expanded trigger wood traps
and places them in the rat runs and near
food
a rat is caught
probably the last wrap
tracking patches are re-smooth and
observed daily for five days
since no rat footprints are found the
storage basement is considered to be rat
free
thereafter as in all rat-free premises
inspection must be made at regular
intervals
for this purpose tracking patches laid
in dark out of the way places provide a
permanent inspection record
there are other types of rodenticides
and as time goes on more will be
developed
but regardless of the rodenticide used
safety for human beings and small
animals as well as effectiveness against
rats must be considered
for greater safety animatic can be added
to many rodenticides
dangerous poisons with which emetics
cannot be used
should be handled only by qualified
personnel
under conditions that present no peril
to human beings or domestic animals
by observing proper rat killing
techniques
rat proof premises can be completely
freed of rats and kept that way
rat killing by itself
without sanitation or rat proofing
must often be used as a temporary
emergency measure
in substandard areas there are
conditions like these
garbage rubbish
rat food and harborage everywhere
sanitation appears to be unknown
obviously under such conditions rat
proofing is impossible
financial health may be needed to
improve or rebuild the section
individual and collective efforts to
clean the place up may take a long time
everywhere there is evidence of rat
infestation
carrying with it a constant danger of
rat-borne disease there have been
several reported cases of children being
bitten by rats
the health officer and sanitary engineer
are faced with a real problem
according to latest health inspection
reports
three blocks in the area have the
highest incidence of rat bite in the
entire city
a survey has shown that the same three
blocks are in the center of a large area
that is heavily rat infested
poisoning operations are planned for
this area
the first rodenticide to be used is red
squill
the safest rat poison known for
residential areas four baits are
selected fresh fish
fresh horse meat rolled oats and scratch
feed
each type of poison base will be
prepared in torpedoes wrapped in a
different color paper
after preparation the four types of
torpedoes are assembled into one pile
then they are thoroughly intermingled so
that when they are distributed the rats
will have a complete choice of baits
the assortment is loaded into carrying
bags
to take full advantage of rat habits
poisoning is planned on a block by block
basis
the men form a working team each man is
assigned a section of the area to cover
in any such program the goodwill and
cooperation of the residents is an
essential factor
the men must inform the occupants of the
purpose of the work
request them to confine pets and not to
allow children to molest the poison
baits
of course with native populations
consideration must be given to their
food habits and no baits used which
might be eaten under the compulsion of
hunger
the eradicator then proceeds to look for
rat signs
at places where he sees rat signs he
deposits clusters of the four baits
the occupant of each house is contacted
the work is explained and consent
obtained for placing the baits
experienced rat control men quickly pick
out rat signs and place the bait
accordingly
active burrows and signs of knowing
indicate the need for a generous supply
of poison
here's a place for many rats
rubbish piles are logical places to
expect rat infestation
hedgerows and shrubbery are usually
honeycombed with rat runs
the area is thoroughly covered bait is
much less expensive than labor and
should be used generously
at dusk the efforts begin to bear fruit
the maximum kill is almost always
achieved on the first attempt
rats surviving the initial poisoning
will become suspicious and avoid the
poison bait
this initial area poisoning therefore
must be thorough
not only must the dwelling areas be
covered but the surrounding territory
also
poisoning must be extended to adjoining
open areas that are reservoirs of rat
infestation
poison baits are distributed
systematically block by block until the
entire area is treated
after a week an inspection is made of
the area
reports are collected on the results of
the poisoning program
reports show that results were
satisfactory in more than 90 percent of
the blocks treated
the remaining areas must be treated
again
for the re-poisoning zinc phosphide is
used with tartar medic added a new group
of materials will be mixed with the
poison
this time it is mixed with cubed apples
zinc phosphide causes gastrointestinal
irritation
cerebral involvement and liver injury
usually causing death within 12 hours
as always the poison is carefully
measured out
in repoisoning each step must be
repeated
the change in rodenticides is explained
to all householders
and the safety factor in the
tartaromatic is pointed out
the men worked swiftly but carefully
seeking out rat signs and distributing a
generous supply of the poison bait
the re-poisoning was successful and
accomplished the temporary control
sought through area poisoning
but much remains to be done
in order for the beneficial effects to
last as long as possible the inspector
must instruct householders on how to cut
down available rat food and to remove
rat harborages
education and enforcement in sanitation
must be constant and progressive
the inspector studies the evidence of
rat infestation on each premise before
contacting the occupant
thus he will be able to make specific
suggestions on solving the particular
problems of each premise
one successful device in this
educational work
is to tag inadequate garbage cans to
emphasize to the owner that replacement
is required
a specific suggestion might be the
removal of a board fence or elimination
of shrubbery giving the rats access to
open windows
a courteous and constructive approach to
the residents will usually evoke
interest and full cooperation
several weeks later three blocks out of
41 originally poisoned require
additional treatment and are scheduled
for repoisoning
to keep down the rat population in
substandard areas is a never-ending job
as long as environmental conditions make
available the basic requirements for rat
life namely food and harborage
in the long run substandard housing must
be eliminated and new construction of
rat proof design provided
when sanitary practices become habitual
depriving rats of their food supply
when rat-proofed buildings are erected
and maintained in good repair
reducing rat harborage
then rat killing becomes the final and
conclusive measure in an integrated
program of rat control
[Music]
you